now we'll call this point of contact
down here let's call it P there's the
point of contact now I want you to draw
from the point of contact a chord in the
circle we haven't talked about chords
since the first lesson on circles do you
remember what a chord is a chord is any
interval that what what makes a quarter
chord that that joins that joins any two
points on the circumference okay so I
have one so pick any literally any other
point on the circumference I'm gonna
pick one over here for instance let's
call this guy eight and we're going to
join up the chord to that point okay now
just a minor piece of notation
terminology for you you know how this is
the point of contact their point of
contact because this chord joins up with
the point of contact we call it I'll use
a different color
it's a chord that joins up with this
point of contact so it's called the
chord of contact I know right it's a
amazing ah so you got a point of contact
you had a chord of contact okay
now the court of contact AP excuse me
you can use it to form an angle on the
circumference of the circle on the
opposite side over here okay so pick any
point you like on the opposite side over
here and join up a finer you know label
it and call it B or whatever you want
actually I'm gonna put my base somewhere
else just to make it easier to
illustrate what I'm about to show you
okay pick that point and then I want you
to drawing up a B P join up that angle
on the circumference
okay the last thing you'll need is just
another point on on this side just so we
can talk about it not to do any more
constructions
because it's on the tangent I'm gonna
call this guy T for tangent right now I
want you to look very closely at your
diagram what I contend what I'm
suggesting what I'm proposing is that
angle TPA T P this is what we required
to prove I'm going to suggest the angle
T PA is equal to angle a B P that guy
over there or the circumference it kind
of even looks equal as you'd hope
because we've properly constructed have
a look at your diagram your diagram
would look a little bit different to
mine the angles might be different in
size that the court of contact might be
different in size but we should still be
able to find this relationship that this
angle here between the tangent and the
court of contact equals this guy over
here up in this corner okay how will we
prove that this is the case okay I'm
going to give you a clear I'm gonna set
you to work the clue is constructions
will be handy I'm not going to tell you
which constructions but maybe you have a
guess as to what constructions if you
think you have something and just for
the sake of consistency let's call this
guy on alpha if you think you can show
that that guy is alpha as well call me
over I'd love to have a look okay off
you go now the clue that I provided to a
few people who wanted it was to
construct some radii okay there are lots
of different radii here in general we
try not to construction of anything
because as you know if it just becomes a
mess of lines you can't see anything
anymore and that's not useful to you
okay so the radar I want you to draw are
the radii that come from the corner
contact okay so in other words from a
and P so I've conveniently already got a
center which is a dent in my whiteboard
so I'm gonna call that O the center and
if you join up Opie
and Oh a because these are radii what
kind of triangle have you formed an
isosceles triangle common theme right so
I'm just going to mark them in okay now
because you joined up the radio to the
point of sorry the court of contact that
means that this radius here this
particular one joins the point of
contact well what do you know about
tangents and the radii at the point of
contact
they're right angles right so this angle
here opa opt sorry opt is right angled
yes which means that opa
in terms of alpha because they add up to
around Ingle together what so PA 19
minus alpha yep 90 minus alpha okay well
if that's 90 minus alpha you told me 30
seconds ago that this is a isosceles
triangle so you know that this is also
90 minus alpha okay
oh by the way just a minor point I even
hear myself saying 90 minus alpha even
though I'm writing down 90 degrees minus
alpha please do write the degrees if you
haven't grown degrees so far the reason
why is because especially you guys are
going to learn within the next 12 to 15
months that degrees are not the only way
to measure angles in fact degrees are a
very poor way of measuring angles when
you want to advance further into
mathematics so when you're measuring
angles and you need degrees say degrees
okay I've got two angles in this
triangle which means I can find the
third point what's this guy 90 minus
alpha 91 is alpha this guy to make the
triangle sum be 180 what does this have
to be two alpha right because it's going
to have to cancel with these - alphas
down here okay
but if this is 2 alpha remember where
we're going right this this has to be
alpha what's the reason
what's the reason because the angle at
the center standing on this arc AP the
angle at the center is double the angle
at the
a conference that's on the same arc
that's really nice you see how they all
come together right it's quite beautiful
okay now how do you state this okay I'm
going to pinch a piece of paper again
this this property the wording for this
property is among the worst of all the
names of the the properties of the
wedding so for that reason it's the only
property I'm aware of on this entire
list for which an abbreviation is
acceptable okay so I'm going to tell you
what the full property is and they'll
tell you what the abbreviation is sorry
Justin I'm gonna pinch this just so that
I can say it properly everyone you might
be able to think about it this is number
10 in terms of this diagram we're just
drawing so it says the angle between a
tangent and what a tangent and what what
is what's it between the chord of
contact the angle between a tangent and
the court of contact which angle does it
equal well it's this angle over here how
can we describe this guy okay I want you
to I want you to think back to when we
were talking about like terminology with
a circle so do you remember if you've
got a chord this chord it divides up the
circle into two parts right you've got
this guy over here and then you've got
this guy over here do you remember what
those two kinds of shapes are chord
starts with an S it's called a segment
not to be confused with a second tour
which is a slice of pizza right so this
is a segment now see this too right well
one's bigger one smaller all right so we
usually call this guy at the major
segment and we would call this one the -
segment okay now that's in terms of size
but depending on how you drew your court
of contact you can make this segment the
bigger one as it is right now or I could
join I put my quarter contact over that
way and you would make this one the
smaller one which would be weird so all
I mean is see how alpha is in this
segment down here I just mean the other
segment what's our word for this when
you've got something and then you've got
the other one we use this we use this
phrase in parallel lines when we say hey
there's this angle and then there's that
other one on the other side we
call these guys alternate angles so this
is the angle in the what segment it's
the alternate segment okay so let me
state the whole thing for you the angle
between the tangent and the chord of
contact equals the angle in the
alternate segment and those last little
words their angle in the alternate
segment that's the abbreviation that
gets accepted because there's no other
property that relates to angles in
alternate segments so in fact there's no
other properties that relate to
alternate segments at all so that we
would have it the course so when you've
written that what I would ask you do is
just underline that last phrase angle in
the alternate segment for this course
and also for Matt's extension one in
which circle geometry is found if you
say angle in the alternate segment
thumbs up we know you made the entire
thing okay right you guys worked really
hard I've showed you a lot of properties
and you've done a great job developing
them so I'm going to stop there well
don't we have one last lesson if not the
left I hope you've had fun so far I I
wouldn't mind having a party I think
you've earned it so um can I ask you
guys to pack up your things they can
pack up thank you again for being
flexible and coming today rather
tomorrow no no so in fact let me draw
you one that isn't I'm gonna redraw it
like this okay
sorry just for everyone while you're
packing up don't draw this but just
watch it because Chloe asked a great
question which was is the alternate
segment always the bigger one and the
answer is no watch this tangent court of
contact now when I say the angle between
the tangent of the court of contact do
you notice there are actually two do you
see that I mean probably the instinctive
one you see is a small one you probably
see this one but it isn't isn't this guy
also between the tangent the court
O'Connor it's just on the other side is
that okay now think about that this
angle I've just drawn the big one is in
the B
segment it's in the major segment right
so where is the alternate segment it's
down here in the corner so what would an
angle in the alternate stay wit look
like for this guy this is what it would
look like look like right see how this
guy's obtuse that's what makes this one
also obtuse okay it's harder to see
because most people instinctively look
for the small one but it's just as true
it's still the angle between the tangent
in the court of contact it's still the
angle in the alternate segment okay good
question